comment tu vois gros fils de sam à
profit
ces constats précédent et vous a fait
plaisir en tout cas ça a coupé il y
avait des gouttes de pluie qui tombait
sur mon téléphone j'ai pas pu pour la
vidéo jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire
qu'il a goûté un mollard alors mehdi est
avec nous bah merci d'être là mais dit
mehdi est ce que déjà tu regrettes ton
juste
regretter mon geste
est un grand mot t'aurais pas aimer
plutôt allé le voir lui parler lui dire
là je suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi
pour ça pour ça est ce que tu dis voilà
sur l'islam ça je suis pas d'accord avec
toi il essayait d'exposer des arguments
en face de lui mais le problème c'est
que en fait c'est quand j'ai fait ce
geste quand j'aurai agressé moi je
regrette pas d'accord je reste sur mes
propos je le regrette pas ce que j'ai
fait c'est
comment ça s'est passé tu le vois dans
la rue tu te dis je vais les libanais
l'agresser mais en fait j'ai reconnu et
je me suis laissé emporter pourquoi tu
avais une haine contre lui
j'ai au début j'ai commencé à parler
tranquillement et
je me suis laissé emporter toutes les
les pics les insultes envers les noirs
les arabes les musulmans le jeune de
quartier
belle réponse en tout cas mais le
problème c'est que
c'est bien pas comment adhère tout ça je
m'appelle mehdi chers jeunes des
quartiers je suis musulman ça renvoyait
une très mauvaise image en fait moi je
pensais pas que ça allait faire tout ça
c'est ça parce que derrière tu as envoyé
une mauvaise image d'envoyer un mauvais
signal c'est ça que tu regrettes surtout
ouais surtout c'est ça que je regrette
parce que après les musulmans les jeunes
de quartiers tu leur as fait mais
voilà les renvoyer à ça ouais tu leur as
fait du mal et c'est vrai que ça c'est
bien que tu en es conscience et que tu
le dis ce soir parce que c'est vrai que
était en faisant ça
c'est tout et c'est toi c'est toi qui
t'es vraiment attardé tout seul est à
bazarder toute une communauté derrière
ouais mais je pense je pensais pas qu'en
fait ça l'était pas c'est autant et mais
quand je clique ce moment derrière
l'événement derrière tu te dis je vais
faire une vidéo en disant parce que tu
es tu es sûr que tu allais de faire
cramer derrière je pensais pas j'avais
un petit peu de monde sur snap la vidéo
elle a commencé à tourner et c'est parti
sur twitter top tweets et après ça et ça
pouvait plus s'arrêter mais mettons j'ai
ton geste il est franchement je te lis
il est inadmissible moi je peux
comprendre tout tu vois je peux
comprendre que tu sois blessé je dis tu
vois tous les soirs ici ya plein de gens
qui sont blessés par les propos d'eric
zemmour sont blessés par ces idées qui
met au contraire tu vois si tu avais été
le voir je pense et que tu lui avait dit
et que les fait penser le contraire de
tout ce qu'ils pensent de la banlieue à
les citer tous la même ça je peux dire
qu'il aurait été encore plus con que ce
que tu as fais là parce que là au
contraire là ça lui a donné raison je
pense aussi
et si je n'avais pas vécu en poche je
pense pas que j'aurai aujourd'hui tu le
vois demain tu fais pas tu tu fais quoi
tu fais pas la même chose non vois tu
lui dirais qu'on est déjà je pense je
leur ai voté âge leur avait apporté ses
cours ce
[Rires]
stade je te sois un peu atterré par ce
qui se passe là sur le plateau et non
mais c'est vrai que tu te rappeler le
président de la génération z ouais voilà
social se coincer un groupe moins on est
avec des moteurs de la santé mondiaux
nature alors dit tout pourquoi quand on
entend ça et quand tu as vu ce geste
fois tu t'es dit quoi bah je me suis dit
c'est pitoyable déjà tu as quel âge je
me dis en plus ça amusant mais parce que
je te dis mais dit c'est que dans cette
vidéo il dit c'est impossible de parler
avec lui il est super fort n'a pas
insulté sa mère vous voulez faire quoi
on met des gens reconnaît qu'il
reconnaisse à l'aspérité de zemmour au
débat non ce qui est quand même dommage
en plus forte ya eu des morts est
quelqu'un qui accepte le débat d'idées
donc il aurait pu tenter de le faire de
rade de après il fait une vidéo le soir
mais à mon avis pour son avocat ou pour
des raisons juridiques en expliquant que
vous regrettiez il n'aurait jamais dû
faire ça un peu une vidéo de pleureuses
où vous dites maintenant c'était
plusieurs jours pour rester toujours
plus toujours plus tard ben ouais voilà
vous avez été d'ailleurs je crois
condamné pour ça c'est bien normal en
tant que vides en plus cracher sur
quelqu'un je suis pas sûr que ça me fait
cracher dessus après je n'avais web
avait menti sur sa alors qu'on faisait
monter sur ça c'était dans le feu de
l'action à dakar dans lequel moi quand
je croise aussi froid jean luc mélenchon
d'art il faut je le suive et dans le feu
de l'action le fait une vidéo instagram
désormais je vais cracher dessus
c'était moi ça moi ça me rend dingue en
fait moi ce qui me rend dingue c'est
d'eric zemmour tous les jours où il
expliquera qu'il ya des pommes de
sécurité viennent même de délinquance
est en fait là on a quelqu'un qui va lui
cracher dessus le type crème indoor faut
le dire le savent aussi eric zemmour ça
fait 30 ans qu'il fait des plateaux la
télé le lien il est tout seul dans la
rue tout seul enfin porter ses sacs sous
la pluie et il est agressé moi je reçois
cet homme normal qui a récemment fait ce
soir sans protection aujourd'hui on
m'a dit il avait 2 by d'abertis sera
candidat à l'image est ce qu'un petit
bolide avec lui en ce moment il ya trois
mois au tchad deux policiers avec lui
pour assurer sa sécurité
c'est déjà pour se faire agresser tous
les jours eric zemmour à sa lancée mais
là quand il ya quelqu'un qui valent
trois étudiants qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui je vais te douter et sur le
camp de la mecque c'est ça aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on lui a dit aujourd'hui à
l'essai d'un besoin de faire et de suite
et on à paris dans la capitale de la
cinquième puissance mondiale aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tout acabit
plus ce qui s'est passé et qu'ils
étaient dans la rue tranquillement en
train de marcher sc
enfin ces policiers je passe les agents
sécurité des policiers et quelqu'un
l'individu est allés vendanger de buter
sur le corps de la mecque on a dû et
filtres eric zemmour a laissé diana on
est dans la capitale on à paris dans la
5 et dans la vue la plus touristique du
monde est en fait un métier exprime des
idées à la télé triste de se faire buter
ou sait menacé de mort mais c'est
scandaleux c'est scandaleux et les gens
apprennent qu'ils disent sur les
plateaux n'y a pas deux comme
d'insécurité à peu près d'insécurité
elle est là elle est là là c'est dur et
noir mais c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça
que moi je rejoins avec quelqu'un comme
eric zemmour par ceux ci arrivent et les
émaux ça arrive à des des centaines et
des centaines de gens quotidiennement de
serre emmerder par des petites racailles
qui en fait tu vois des petits vieux des
des mamies et ils sont agressifs envers
d'aimer ça c'est tous les jours